[Music]
shrines played an essential part in
breath of the wild's narrative a way for
link to recollect his lost power
after his 100 year resurrection hangover
most shrines tucked away in hyrule's
landscape are visible and accessible
from the very get-go but a select few
lie buried beneath the surface and
require a bit of overworld detective
work before they reveal themselves
to the south east of the map bordering
the nekluda sea we find
one such shrine the kaya shrine located
on palmerea beach and inside what is
known as the palmarea ruins
just a stone throws away from the
tropical fishing village of laurellin
amidst the ruins we find one of this
town's villagers by the name of garini
who's examining an ancient stone tablet
stating that he recently discovered
mysterious writings carved into it and
is making an attempt to decipher them
however due to an earthquake a while
back the monument broke apart with its
missing pieces having been scattered
along the coastline by the tides
garini then requests link to track down
the three missing shards and take a
picture of them so he can get a complete
image of the writings and translate it
in full
upon doing so gourini is able to
translate the ancient text which
according to him says the following when
the two find their place and neo in
reverence the shrine will reveal itself
for some reason gorini has no clue what
to do next
strange for a guy who's smart enough to
decipher ancient texts
but luckily most of us had an easy time
figuring this one out you knew on the
pedestal as gharini follows your example
and
voila the shrine finally appears now
this is all well and good but we're not
here to talk about the shrine or even
the quest leading up to it but rather
the stone monument itself
ever since people stumbled upon this
ancient tablet back in 2017 they were
quick to draw comparisons to
a particular artifact from a previous
zelda game
the mirror of twilight from the legend
of zelda twilight princess
and i can see why both are shaped like a
circle have a dark grey color to them
and both were shattered into four pieces
with three of them missing
due to the similarities people in some
cases have been outright calling it the
mirror of twilight but
is that really the case is there really
a connection between the two or is it
just
a coincidental design choice well let's
take a closer look shall we
despite having solved the shrine puzzle
the stone monument itself
is never actually reassembled in game as
the pictures link took of the missing
shards were sufficient enough for
gharini to
translate the ancient writings so we
never get to see the slab in its
complete form luckily with the help of
super secret csi computer technology we
can extract the model from the game's
files
one interesting detail is that despite
the fact that all four pieces are
located quite far away from each other
at all times
they are all part of one single 3d model
which the level designers then spread
out across the map
inside the engine i didn't even have to
reassemble it myself
so is this monument supposed to be the
mirror of twilight
in my honest opinion no and there's a
couple of reasons
first we have the little fact that the
mirror was well
completely destroyed at the end of
twilight princess not split into pieces
but like totally obliterated by mitna
not exactly a
irrelevant detail i would say unless
someone built a new mirror somewhere
down the line which would make it a
replica
there is no way that the two artifacts
could be the same but even if a replica
did exist
there are far too many differences
between the two first of all there's a
clear difference in dimensions
the mirror of twilight is bigger both in
width and length while the stone slab is
thicker the decorations on the two also
differ quite a lot the monument only has
one outer ring decorated with text
and two disconnected half circles in the
center one of which has an outer bevel
while the other has an inner one
the mirror on the other hand has two
outer rims a circle in the center that
sticks out quite far
and with ornaments of a triforce symbol
two serpents among some other little
decorations around it
the back side of the mirror or the front
side depending on how you look at it
is also well a mirror a reflective
surface decorated with a complex
geometry
while the back side of the monument is
just a flat surface devoid of any
details the pedestal the mirror stands
on is also quite embellished and seems
to have been made from metals
whereas the stone tablet sits on two
stone feet so to speak
so no i do not believe the two have a
connection lore wise
could it still at least be a reference
to the mirror of twilight
sure maybe i mean anything is possible
then again
if it was then i wonder why the designs
are so radically different from one
another we can find clear references to
past games
like the crest in the castle sanctum
which is pretty much one for one to the
crests on the gates of time from skyward
sword or the three springs which are
also pretty close to the ones from
skyward sword as well
so why is the stone tablet so different
from the mirror of twilight if it was
supposed to be a reference
you would at least expect to see some of
the same decorations like maybe a faded
out triforce or the two serpents
even the file name of the 3d model
itself doesn't really say much
as it's simply called field object
search stone
very creative nintendo i think it's more
likely that the slight resemblance
between the stone tablet and the mirror
is just a coincidence there's only so
many base shapes they could have gone
with to create a monument and they
happen to have gone with a cylindrical
shape
this of course doesn't dispute a
possible connection between the zonai
and the twilight
interlopers in general i gotta be honest
i'm not entirely convinced of the
connection yet but there are definitely
some similarities that are worth
mentioning
i won't get into the twilight zone
connection here as i know of a certain
someone who is doing a very big video on
that topic very soon
and will surely be able to explain it in
way more detail than i ever could here
instead since we're here anyway let's
take a look at the one thing that does
make this piece of ancient stone masonry
special
even without being derivative of the
mirror of twilight which is of course
the mysterious writings that glow in the
dark
we've already discussed in the past that
the writings are most likely glowing
because they were made using luminous
stones which
does have a connection to the zonai of
the farren region to some degree
and some of the other structures that
make up the pomeraya ruins are
unmistakably of zonai origin
however i don't want to get too deep
into the zone eye specifically in this
video
but more so what the existence of these
writings mean because anyone who's
researched or studied anything zonai
related in breath the wild's overworld
knows that the zonai
don't seem to have had any writings none
of their prominent architecture features
anything more than stylized decorations
like swirls snake patterns and other
ornaments but never anything that looks
like an actual alphabet or even
hieroglyphics really even in the breath
while 2 trailer the only thing we can
find are cave paintings of what is
presumably ganondorf and other humanoid
beings alongside him
so how did this one single monument
suddenly feature writings which can be
translated into modern day sentences
this is not a strange question to ask
because so far the only written
languages in the zelda series we can
actually translate are hylian which
comes in a few different versions
chica writings and gerudo and in breath
of the wild these are the only written
languages we can find in the entire game
except for this one stone monument and
it gets even weirder when you think
about the implications
of this text it's supposed to serve as a
hint to open up the ancient shika shrine
but if this is
ancient zonai writing the only known
rendition of it how would they
referring to the ones who originally
carved the monument know that a shika
shrine was going to be built here
we know that the shika repurposed a
variety of different ruins to serve as a
shrine puzzle but not just those of
zonai origin but also ancient gerudo and
ancient hylian as well
so that kinda leaves us with two
different options either the zonai were
alive 10
000 years ago and were working with the
shika to create the shrine puzzle or the
shika themselves carved it into this
tablet and instead of their own language
they somehow knew the zonai alphabet and
recreated it on this monument
either way the ancient chica have some
explaining to do
as far as we know around the time that
breath the wild takes place
gorini is the only one in hyrule who
seems to understand this foreign
alphabet and is able to translate it
accordingly
unfortunately he never tells us how he
came to know the ancient texts and
decipher it whether he
and his people have any ties to this
mysterious language
or if he's just a genius at cryptography
there's already plenty of theories about
the people of laurellin and their
possible connection or even ancestry to
the zone eye so i'm gonna leave that one
up for debate for now what i would like
to know is if the text on the monument
is complete gibberish
just random symbols and nothing more or
if there's any rhyme or reason to it
i've counted the amount of characters in
the translated sentence and excluding
spaces periods and commas
it's a total of 68. on the tablet i
count approximately 64. though it's hard
to say for sure where one character
stops or starts like is this one symbol
or
two i expect that it's just random but
who knows
even if it is now maybe someday it will
be fleshed out into a real language
i'm pretty sure i'm not the first to
have made an attempt to make sense of it
but so far nobody's been able to
not that i'm aware of anyway and with a
texture as low res as this one it's
kinda hard to see the finer details of
each of the symbols
what is for sure is that whatever this
language is it is unique to any other
alphabet we've seen in the zelda series
before
it doesn't have the kanji type of
structure hylian has
or the square and blocky characteristics
of shika writings nor the elegant swirls
and curls of gerudo
rather it seems like a bit of a mishmash
there are some very angular symbols like
triangles and brackets
some curvy ones and some very simple
ones like a circle
like i said it's definitely unlike any
other alphabet found in the series
though i do want to highlight that this
is definitely not the first language
we've seen that we don't have a
translation for in twilight princess for
example we find the sky book which
contains the ancient writings of the oka
and since we oh my gosh is that a so
nice world
that was weird anyway since we only ever
get to see six characters of the oka
alphabet it's unlikely we'll ever get a
full translation of it
now i know that some of you in the
comments are already making connections
between the zonai writings and the
swirling energy in the breath while 2
trailer
and you know what i'm totally down with
that but as of right now i
don't really see it yet i'm definitely
missing some of the more angular symbols
here
as for those who are big proponents of
the twilight connection that too cannot
be ruled out
as far as we know we've never seen the
alphabet the twilight use
it could be that they simply use hylian
since they seem to speak highly into
link and ganondorf and zen too
seem to be able to understand each other
just fine but who knows maybe they did
develop their own written language
alongside it whatever the case may be
this is one mystery i definitely do hope
we can one day label as
solved thanks a lot for watching
and as always a big thanks to my
patreons and members for supporting my
channel financially
we've got tanner kossik lovelust heart
dan gamble
pedro faguera and my very own cousin
mikey joining the cause
thank you all so much and uh mikey i'll
be seeing you at the e3 live stream
it's gonna be hype that is all for now
and hopefully i will see you in the next
video
this is dawn signing off and have a good
one
[Music]
you